The Carolingian Empire crumbled. Europe was attacked from all sides.
In the south, the Saracens invaded Crete, Sicily, Tuscany, Rome, and Provence,
where a beachhead was set up near Saint-Tropez.
From the Asiatic steppes, the Magyars crossed the Danube Plain and headed for Lombardy,
Venetia, Bavaria, Burgundy, Provence, and Rome.
And from the north came waves of Vikings, or Normans,
who appeared on European soil in the early 800s.
But let's not go too fast. Let's go back to 790.
We are about to pay a visit to these fierce warriors, these lords of the sea.
Life seems more peaceful than warlike.
Our friend Lurch is a trail, a born serf.
Bert is a bond, a free man who carries a sword.
Here he comes to give his trusted servant a hand.
We manage.
Try this.
Oh, good idea.
Here comes Jarl, or Chief.
All right, all right.
Accompanied by his own trusted manservant.
Do.
Don't make fun of the master.
Yeah, this'll do some good.
Slave, come here.
What?
What's so funny?
That's my own man-servant.
Hmm.
That's knotted scarf shows that she's a married woman.
The chain of keys and scissors she wears shows that she's also the degia, or mistress of the house.
Come in.
Wait.
I've got a brilliant solution.
There you go.
Minute.
No, period. Monogamy hasn't been invented yet. You'll just have to wait.
Roasted seaweed.
That's all I've got left.
Before long, we'll have all the whales we want. Just big.
Hey, why don't we have a beer?
Here you go, man.
Oh, no, not you. You'll have to wait, 'til you grow up.
Whoa!
These newborns have spent the night lying unprotected outside the village stockade.
Weighs a ton!
...orders all the men leave to begin the fishing season.
Keith's wives and his children, legitimate and otherwise, have come to wave goodbye to their lord and master.
Prepares birchbark bread, food for times of famine.
What do you say we go hunting for Iderdale?
I'm ready when you are.
Let's go!
Wait up!
Doesn't pay, my boy.
Hold on a minute, children. Here. These are for you.
Try and keep still.
See whales.
What?
I'm telling you.
Huh?
You say so.
A single one up from a group.
Full basket of down. Give it to me.
You could do just as well.
By the time the boats head for home, all that is left on the shore is a pile of bones.
And so the hunt has been a successful one.
The race is on to reach home.
We'll pay for that.
Just you wait, you.
The festival of the summer solstice will begin.
Maestro, the wise elder, gives the signal.
In front of the altar to the gods, Thor, by his side, Odin, and Frey.
Kneel!
Peace, you're right there!
This meat or strong deer here.
Taste.
Have to make sure it's good.
This.
You're good, very strong.
Some more.
Just a little sip.
See what happens.
Yeah.
Anything about booze.
I never drank that before, never.
In the foreground, we see the men's table.
The women sit in the back with the children in the middle.
And here are the menfolk dressed up for the occasion.
Toast to the great feast of the summer solstice.
And the gods who hold me in their favor.
I was a little bird and a little ranch who did it, not me.
Right, my fine fellows, you not only insult my son, you dare to insult me, your chief.
Won't be long, you'll see who's boss here.
Doom make examples for all the others.
Hold on there.
Come over here.
One moment.
Just a minute, my friends.
According to the law, this must be settled by a duel.
It was the custom for the opponents to meet at the Yggdrasil, or a Tree of Life, where the duel would take place.
The distance will be 15 meters.
Good.
Here, catch this.
What the?
Good, at my signal.
Ready or not?
One, two, uh, one second!
Have to go on to the next test.
Here, go ahead.
Turn.
Why don't you?
What are you waiting for?
Oh no, it's unbelievable.
I won!
Uh...
Chief has disgraced the Viking's honor. Banish him!
Yeah! Chief has no respect for the Viking's laws! He's got to leave!
Understood. They put you out. You're now an outlaw. You must never return to this village.
You're banished!
That's...
But big fish were not the only food for the Vikings.
One morning, Maestro and his young friends...
Do you realize how high those salmon are jumping?
I've got an idea. Try these.
Now look, why don't we do it like the fish? Like this.
Or maybe like that, or even...
Why sure, why not?
Why didn't I think of it sooner?
Eureka! I found it! I found it!
I found it! Oh wow!
I found it by Cracky, I found it!
Just copy the salmon!
We can jump right over whatever's in the way!
Why don't we do what Maestro says? Let's try!
Hey!
There's something in the way! Let's disembark here!
The boat on these logs! And roll it!
Take it! Keep going! Keep going!
Their method was light boats. No reason we couldn't attack the upland villages, eh?
Is there?
Just what do we do?
Lucky thing.
We'll show them whose town this is.
Dead chief's side replaced his weapons, shields, his jewels, and the food he'll need during his long voyage.
His eldest son has the honor of lighting the pyre.
No, there's nothing sad here, for Odin, god of warriors, has a place of honor waiting for he who dies a brave death.
And revenge was taken over and over in a vicious cycle of plunder and attack.
Land became one vast battlefield.
Looting is forbidden among the Norsemen.
Instead, let's work together to build great ships
so that we can travel far to find food,
women, wealth, slaves, and land
for our children to kill.
One.
92.
Do hold your horses.
How true.
Steam planks on either side riveted together,
overlapping slightly.
Ships are ready.
Now you must elect a chief.
One of these candidates must lead the first expedition.
Make your choice.
Must all swear loyalty to him.
Go ahead.
Chief! Long live the chief!
Do it!
Everything all right?
It might work, but I'll be needing some cow hair!
There you go!
That's my stroke!
Everything seemed to check out fine. 23 meters 33 by 5 meters 25.
Height 1 meter 95, water level 85 centimeters.
Or locks 1 meter apart. Looks fine.
Length of oars? 4 meters 50.
My, look how solid those shields look.
Good, now let's get her into the water.
Fine. Load the horses!
Will do, most definitely. That will not do.
What if we tried it this way?
No, the poor thing would get dizzy.
How about that?
Hop!
A little risky.
What if he jumps in?
What if he falls overboard and...
That's it, that's the answer!
There, my friends, bring back the horse now.
Just tip the boat, and he'll climb aboard easily.
How did I ever get such an idea?
Begins. Each ship contains 2,500 kilos of provisions, 400 kilos of weapons, and 40 men.
Each man's coffer will double as his seat while he rows.
And remember, no fires on board, eat your food cold, and here's my latest invention.
It will help you navigate.
With it, you'll keep right on course.
Fine, we're about ready.
Want to come with us?
You're a man now.
Frog as thick as this one, it's not easy to use Maestro's instrument.
The chief decides to release some crows.
Come back, we've got to be close to shore.
The year is 793.
The island of Lindisfarne off the coast of Northumbria in northern England
was the site of the first Viking ring.
Joyce in the grave.
Now it's up to you, my youngest, to go in search of new treasures.
Okay.
Farewell, son, and good luck.
830, the Vikings headed for Ireland.
Torgs Hill, the Norwegian chief, decided to make it his own.
In 839, he was proclaimed King of Ulster.
By 840, the Vikings ruled the Low Countries,
and the Danes had sailed up the Seine River as far as Rouen.
843, it's Midsummer's Day in the French city of Nantes.
44, the Vikings followed the River Garonne into Toulouse on their way to Spain.
In 845, 120 ships sailed up the Seine and sacked Paris.
In 850, it was the Thames, the Sennegan, and the Loire.
856 and 57, Paris was in flames.
In 859, the conqueror Hastings took his 62 ships and left the same.
His ships rounded the coast of Spain and sailed past Gibraltar to conquer the Moors in Morocco.
They sacked Murcia, the Balearic Islands of Russo and Camargue in France.
The next goal was Italy, Pisa and Luna.
But here at last, they met with solid resistance.
Got an idea. If you disguise yourself behind your weapons...
Beloved chief, the noble Hastings was killed in battle.
His last wish was to have a pious burial.
All his treasures will go to the church.
I'm sent.
Roman turn would be burned.
In 862, Hastings made his triumphal return to his base in Ratmoutier,
where his war plunder was shown to all.
In the same year, the Vikings left Sweden to fly Russia's rivers.
The Volkov, the Dnieper, the Volga.
Rurik founded Kiev, the first Russian state.
At about that time, the Varangians had reached Constantinople.
870. East England was conquered by the Danes.
874. Fair-haired Harold succeeded in unifying the Norwegians, who had soon found Reykjavik in Iceland.
880. France, Belgium, and Germany were invaded.
Viking ships wreaked havoc all along the Seine.
The Somme, the Schelp, the Meuse, the Rhine.
885. Paris was under siege.
700 ships were deployed for a distance of over 3 kilometers.
Charles the Fat bought the retreat of the invaders for 700 pounds of silver.
In 9-11, Charles the Simple gave the Norman chieftain Rolo a present.
Normandy, a region already familiar with Vikings.
Rolo pledged allegiance to the king.
982, Eric the Red sets foot in Greenland.
Other explorers get as far as Newfoundland and the American continent.
1028, Newt the Great reigned over Denmark, Norway, and England.
1059, Robert Grusgard became Duke of Puglia in Calabria.
1061, with his father, he snatched Sicily away from the Arabs.
This time, it was the Normans who arrived in Constantinople by way of the Balkans.
William of Normandy landed in England to claim the throne.
King Harald came to meet him. The result was the Battle of Hastings, and William became King of England.
The Vikings were warriors, but also traders and colonizers.
They were instrumental in extending the limits of the world of their time,
and so their voyage through history was more than just a series of bloody battles.
And in 1096, those who had been the most fervent of Norman pagans would join the Crusades and lead the Christians into battle.